on this friday night another step closer
to normal ottawa's blanket advisory
against non-essential travel is gone but
pcr tests are staying for now the
pandemic is very much alive plus the
timeline on when canada's biggest
province will remove all restrictions
fatal accident alec baldwin fires a prop
gun killing this cinematographer really
generous really talented really upbeat
the risks of film industry firearms
rogers family feud the high stakes fight
for a telecom giant gets messy and
they're not just in the movies anymore
they're waiting in the wings flying cars
designed by canadians
[Music]
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight sophie louie good
evening and thanks for joining us that
holiday you've been dreaming about since
the start of the pandemic is getting
closer for more than 19 months we've
been hunkering down but now ottawa is
opening up travel for the vaccinated
lifting its advisory against
non-essential trips this is typically
the time of year canadians think about
booking a winter getaway but before you
check for flights health officials warn
there are some factors you need to keep
in mind and some forms of travel which
are not advisable and then there's the
issue of affordability of your first
post-pandemic vacation a trip now
includes the high cost of pcr tests
required for visitors in many countries
and upon your return to canada but a
hint today that could also change down
the road abigail beeman has our top
story tonight
after a blanket warning against
non-essential travel blanket at the
global affairs site since the start of
the pandemic the agency quietly updated
the website now warning travelers should
be fully vaccinated no now is not the
the time to just freely go wherever
officials say you should consider your
own health the state of covet 19 where
you're going and the type of trip you're
taking cruise travel outside canada is
still not advised for example and in
terms of that cumbersome and potentially
expensive pcr test canada still requires
travelers to take before entering our
country we're in the middle of
consulting with the provinces as we
speak and on what the needs are for
testing with regards to vaccinated
travelers
i have to remind people that the
pandemic is very much alive outside of
canada health officials also shared a
number of vaccine-related updates friday
the national advisory committee on
immunization now says people who had a
severe allergic reaction after a first
dose can get their second shot after
speaking to their doctor they should be
monitored for longer with someone
familiar with anaphylaxis present we
hope this is good news for people who've
been worried about their allergic
reaction we also got some new
information on booster shots health
canada has submissions from both moderna
and pfizer and friday pfizer released
some clinical trial data showing an
immunity boost after a third dose up to
95.6 percent full data hasn't yet been
released we expect to get that file to
all of the regulators uh shortly so
we'll look through that data uh both for
pfizer and for the moderna vaccines and
then based on that
we'll take a look at authorization while
there isn't yet national guidance the
initial focus for any booster shots
would be on the most vulnerable
including the oldest canadians in
general dr tam says there is still time
to be thoughtful about a booster dose
strategy given most canadians only got
their second dose a few months ago
abigail beeman global news ottawa
the ontario government says a milestone
has been reached in the fight against
covet 19. it has announced a further
easing of capacity limits amid declining
case counts it's good news for the
province's bars restaurants and gyms
there's even a target date to remove all
coveted restrictions but as jamie
morocco reports some are still sounding
a note of caution
andre yakovenko is eager to be fully
open after more than a year of covert
restrictions and lost revenue it's been
a challenge we're probably still missing
well over 50 percent of our client base
at midnight on october 25th ontario
businesses requiring proof of
vaccination will again be allowed to
operate at full capacity with the goal
of removing all precautionary measures
masking vaccine passports social
distancing by the end of march by march
we hope we've maximized our immunization
strategy in ontario that we have more
ontarians immunized to the point that
this virus doesn't have a host in which
it can reproduce this includes first and
second doses for kids from 5 to 11 and
booster shots for at least some but
there is concern the province may be
jumping the gun
it's only been two weeks since arenas
cinemas concert venues and theaters
opened back up to full capacity and
health experts say this plateau may not
be permanent we need to wait still a few
days until we start to understand how
this last step of the reopening process
actually impacts us patients that could
help ontario avoid the same mistakes as
other provinces where critical care
units are still struggling with the
consequences of reopening too soon or
take finland and denmark two northern
countries facing climbing cases after
lifting most public measures if we do
not see the numbers in a stable place
we just aren't going to do it it's as
simple as that small businesses say
another lockdown could be crushing i
think it might be too late for some but
those that are able to make a go of it
this will really help ontario says that
any businesses that want to fully reopen
will just have to enforce the vaccine
passport program something it plans to
get rid of by january 17th and if icu's
remain in good standing and case counts
continue to drop off march 28th is the
day ontarians can circle with cautious
optimism for a return to normal jamie
morocco global news toronto
a 56 year old senator from northern
ontario is in hospital with covet 19
despite being fully vaccinated it's
unclear how senator jose forres nissing
contracted covet 19 her office confirms
she was fully vaccinated earlier this
year adding the senator is grateful for
the messages of support she's received
and the excellent care the hospital and
its staff are giving her foreign singh
was appointed to the senate in 2018.
well if you lose your job because you
refuse to get a covet-19 vaccine you may
not be eligible for employment insurance
benefits in an interview on this week's
edition of the west block employment
minister carla qualtro explained what
factors would be considered that would
disqualify someone from e.i
if an employer has a clear policy with
clear consequences um and and and it's
well understood that non-compliance so
this condition of employment could lead
to dismissal um if they are dismissed
they typically would not be able to
access ei for this reasons because of
course um a fundamental principle of the
aya program is that claimants have to
lose their employment employment through
no fault of their own
and this would be seen typically as a
choice
there's some promising new data from
pfizer on the effectiveness of its covet
19 vaccine in children the company says
results from its clinical trial show the
vaccine is 90.7 percent effective at
preventing symptomatic covet 19 in
children aged 5 to 11. the data was
submitted to the u.s food and drug
administration which is reviewing the
evidence just over 2 200 children were
part of the pfizer trial 750 of them
were given a placebo the rest were given
a 10 microgram vaccine dose that's one
third of the dose given to adults only
three of the children who got the
vaccine contracted covet-19 and there
were no cases of severe illness and the
company says the dosage given to
children was safe u.s experts are set to
meet next week to debate whether the
pfizer shots are safe and effective for
kids pfizer has also submitted initial
data to health canada and that review is
ongoing
well there is an update tonight on the
water crisis in iqaluit the federal
government is sending in military
support on twitter public safety
minister bill blair tweeted ottawa has
approved none of its request for the
canadian forces help to provide the
city's residents access to safe drinking
water
officials in iqaluit say more tests will
be underway as their investigation
suggests contaminated soil and
groundwater around the city's treatment
plant likely seeped into the tank the
news comes 11 days after a high
concentration of fuel was found in a
water tank contaminating iqaluit's
entire water supply about 8 000
residents and iqaluits hospital still do
not have access to clean tap water as
the city works to flush contaminants out
of the system it's a family feud
straight out of a movie script but this
one is playing out in the boardroom of a
canadian telecommunications giant the
leadership of rogers and its board are
in turmoil after a pocket dial to the
ceo the globe and mail says joe natalie
overheard the plan to oust him on an
accidental call and now a battle over
who will take charge is leaving one
member of the rogers family on the
outside looking in eric sorenson
explains
rogers a telecommunications colossus
founded by the late ted rogers spans
wireless cable and internet to mass
media and ownership of the toronto blue
jays what is normally kept private in
the corporate offices has spilled into
public view after edward rogers ted's
son tried to replace the company's ceo
joe natalie soon rogers and other family
members were on opposite sides and so
this is a fight within the family not a
fight within general shareholders and
therefore it's quite different than what
we normally see in business other big
names have been swept into the fray a
former ontario premier david peterson is
a board member and the mayor of toronto
john tory a family friend who sits on
the rogers family trusts advisory board
and tried to mediate the feud
to assert control edward rogers the
company's board chairman tried to
replace five board members including
peterson with five new members the board
which includes roger's mother and his
two sisters balked then voted to replace
rogers as chair insert board member john
mcdonald in his place and retain the
board of directors
edward rogers still a board member has
now moved again to replace the five
members this time in his capacity as
chair of the family trust that controls
the company's voting shares in a
statement the controlled trust chair
edward rogers says he has lost
confidence in the board of rogers
communications rogers board was taken
aback stating the company is not aware
of this mechanism ever having been
utilized in respect of a public company
in canada and will look into the
legality of this course of action in all
my years involved in governance and
boards i've never heard of someone being
able to do this
the election of directors typically
takes place at a shareholders meeting
with
proper notice and everything like that
there has always been a fascination in
popular culture with the personal
infighting and family business empires
i want to see what other news operations
we can sweep up and just like a
television script the stakes are sky
high because rogers is in the midst of
trying to buy shaw communications for 26
billion dollars so how do you stop that
process and change the team midstream it
just puts everything at risk
you know edward could not have chosen a
poor time to start a boardroom battle
the shaw merger would make rogers the
largest telecommunications company in
the country the family clearly have to
figure out what they're going to do this
will be a very dominant company and we
really need stability in our
telecommunications companies because we
rely on them so much rogers board of
directors says it remains committed to
merging with shaw but will there be a
house cleaning of the board itself
before that happens eric sorensen global
news toronto
tragedy strikes the set of an alec
baldwin movie coming up the accident
that left a director of photography dead
plus new charges four decades after a
real estate heirs wife vanished
[Music]
he rose to fame in the early 80s and
tonight hollywood is mourning the loss
of bosom buddies star peter scolari the
actor shared the screen with tom hanks
in that series and later appeared as a
self-absorbed tv producer on new heart
scolari won an emmy in 2016 for his
guest appearance in the hbo comedy girls
scolari had been battling cancer peter
scolari dead at the age of 66.
alec baldwin is speaking up about a
deadly incident on the set of his new
movie in new mexico the hollywood star
pulled the trigger of a prop gun the
film's promising young cinematographer
helena hutchins was killed the director
was wounded jackson prescott reports on
the shooting and what's known about how
it happened
the new mexico desert is now the scene
of a hollywood tragedy after a deadly
accident on the set of the film rust
involving a prop gun fired by actor alec
baldwin
the film's cinematographer helena
hutchins was killed director joel souza
injured in a tweet baldwin wrote there
are no words to convey my shock and
sadness adding i'm fully cooperating
with the police investigation to address
how this tragedy occurred
baldwin is also a producer on the film
he was interviewed by the county
sheriff's office thursday
variety reports the gun may have
contained a live single round citing an
email allegedly sent by a film workers
union to its members i think when people
hear terms like blanks or prop guns they
assume there's no risk whatsoever is
that the case that is really not the
case unfortunately brian detling is a
specialist in prop firearm safety and
training he warns prop guns can be
dangerous even when loaded with blank
ammunition once you get within
like a five to ten foot range on that
that can still cause damage 42 year old
hutchins was considered a rising star
behind the camera her final post to
instagram showed her riding horses on
her day off in the desert i think ward
incredible is not to even beginning to
describe her personality really generous
really talented really upbeat prop gun
tragedies have rocked hollywood before
actor brandon lee was killed in 1993
while filming the crow
this latest tragedy will likely force a
deeper look at onset safety as the film
industry grapples with the real risks
posed by props
jackson prosko global news washington
there's more major legal trouble for
notorious real estate heir robert durst
after being convicted of killing his
best friend
he's now facing charges in the death of
his first wife
kathy durst was 29 years old when she
vanished in 1982 in southern new york
her body has never been found last week
robert durst was sentenced to life in
prison in california for killing his
best friend susan berman back in 2000
police claim berman helped durst cover
up his wife's murder and was about to
confess her role when durst killed her
as well durst is 78 years old his
lawyers say he's on a ventilator in
hospital after contracting covet 19.
the investigation into an international
student's murder ahead the new arrest
police in nova scotia just made
you're watching global national
[Music]
there's been a breakthrough in a murder
case in nova scotia two men have been
arrested in connection with the killing
of prabjot singh catchery police are
searching for a third suspect the sick
man was found dead outside an apartment
building in early september back then
family and friends wondered if it was a
hate crime now as ross lord reports
police may be one step closer to
answering that question
for six in halifax there should be a
time for looking forward an expanded
temple of worship is nearing completion
to better serve a growing congregation
but the sikh community has recently been
consumed with grief following last
month's murder of 23 year old prabhjot
singh khatri at an apartment building in
truro in the absence of any obvious
motive for his fatal stabbing nova
scotia 6 have voiced concerns prabhjot
singh may have been a victim of a hate
crime
statistics canada says violent hate
crimes have increased across canada
during the pandemic
but true police say they found the
person responsible we've arrested a male
20 years of age from pikto landing first
nation
he's been arrested for murder two other
men have been charged with being
accessories after the fact but police
say the details will have to wait until
the case goes to court i can't speculate
on the motive so
just suffice to say that we took
every every opportunity to look at
things through all sorts of different
lenses in this investigation and looking
at the lens of a hate crime potential
hate crime was one of those lenses that
we looked at
prabhjot singh came to canada to study
he was working two jobs in truro sending
money back to india for his single
mother his killing has spread fear
throughout the sikh community here the
maritime sex society says solving the
case is crucial before it undermines
nova scotia and canada's reputation as a
welcoming destination we are all feeling
relieved
i'm more hopeful that justice will be
served
and all young people who are feeling
very anxious and some somewhat
disheartened will get reassured that
their lives matter simardi pondal hopes
the outcome of the murder case helps her
community celebrate its new place of
worship with less bitterness and anxiety
than it's experienced in recent weeks
ross lord global news halifax
the 21st century
transportation space travel
next when fiction meets reality
electric vehicles will one day be the
only things on the road and the next big
change to how we get around is already
in production the flying car industry is
taking off and it's a crowded
competitive field at the forefront is a
company called opener what began as a
dream in the basement of an ontario
man's home has taken flight in
california's silicon valley global's the
new reality got a behind-the-scenes look
donna friesen is here with more on a
canadian television exclusive donna
flying cars are no longer fiction
they're becoming reality
a number of companies have been quietly
working on them for years and at the
forefront is a canadian marcus lang he's
an engineer and inventor whose company
created black fly it's a personal aerial
vehicle and lang tells us it will soon
be on sale
he says he was able to produce a vehicle
with a powerful electric motor that
doesn't need a runway to take off and
land black is sleek and designed for
just one person in the united states
which is our primary market we have
very serious weight restrictions
so the american
vehicles have a 20 plus mile range
foreign operator that's 200 pounds in
canada we don't have those weight
constraints and also we don't have speed
constraints
for years lang has been quietly working
in secret trying to keep his prototype
hidden only in the last few years has
the public seen glimpses of blackfly
it wasn't until the first time that i
saw it fly it kind of dawned on me what
possibilities there could be with this
product it was pretty incredible to make
all this happen lang needed creative and
innovative talent and he recruited
people from canada even though he
couldn't tell them what they would
actually be working on they followed him
to the silicon valley in california will
have their personal stories and much
more on flying cars saturday on the new
reality
very intriguing thanks donna that is
global national for this friday night
i'm sophie louis tonight's your canada
is similacamine bc we love seeing your
canada please email your pictures to
viewers at globalnational.com
robin gill will be back at the anchor
desk this weekend have a great night
[Music]